okay so today the longest running show
here in vegas ends its longest
intermission ever we're talking about
legends in concert
it is finally getting back on stage
tonight over at the tropicana
like many other shows the program at the
tropicana was
paused by the pandemic our own legend in
concert is hector mejia
he's live at the top this morning with a
sneak peek hey hector
[Applause]
well thank you hey there good morning
guys you know what makes this show so
special we get to hear live singing from
the performers on stage and they're also
excited to finally
be in front of an audience all over
again and ladies and gentlemen we have a
surprise for you
just take a look here we have vivian
roscott tina turner
is back tonight good morning to you
morning love thank you for having us
thanks for joining us this early in the
morning all right so you've been uh
rehearsing we gotta hear it we gotta
hear it
we'll be rolling rolling on a river
come on down to legends tonight we open
tonight
and every weekend after how are we
opening tonight everyone is ready and
excited
yes we're way excited i'm going to fall
off the stage i've been spinning and
twirling in my basement
since i found out i could come back to
work and we're very excited we didn't
know what was going on with the
entertainment industry out here so
it's been a blessing i'm so happy to go
on stage i hope everybody comes out to
support this
you're going to get live vocals live
band
lot i mean live entertainment is really
coming back and we're all live the
dancers are ready they're beautiful the
showgirls are ready
frank of course is always ready and our
elvis and our routes do it i'm so
looking forward to opening tonight
and it's also in the name it's a
legendary show in town
forever tell us a little bit about it
it's been here for over 30 years i've
been a part of the company for a good
12 15 years so and we travel all over
the world we have all these different
outlets at least 30 properties that they
perform at
and so i'm just happy some of the
properties opened before we
did so again we just wasn't sure and
it's the perfect timing for tina because
she's being inducted into the hall of
fame as she should have been a long time
ago
but she's finally going in so i'm proud
to play this
empowering woman on stage what was it
like
day one of rehearsals you were just
sharing with me how excited you were
i overdid it i overdid it i sang more i
danced harder i was just
so excited so excited and everybody was
excited we're excited to see each other
the folks that knew each other
the new people that's coming into the
show the tech the crew
everybody's ready we're just it's just
we just want to get this energy out
we've been bottled up for 14 15 months
so you can just imagine what the show is
going to be when when we hit and we have
a crowd and people scream we get live
people there so i'm so excited to be on
tonight
so exciting and congratulations and we
all missed you guys we really did
we really did so we're going to be
missed we'll see you tonight
legends in concert tropicana 7 30 come
early get a drink
we're ready
[Applause]
all right reporting live hector mejia
and
vivian ross got also known as tina
turner come roll down the river
back to you guys and have a wonderful
morning oh so
exciting hector sounds amazing it's a
it's a fun show it's been around for
such a long time great that they're
coming back i
appreciate that sir good stuff at 6 39
here